black panther wakanda forever continues
to devour movie theaters but the claws
are out from fans about some aspects of
Marvel's latest Blockbuster warning
spoilers ahead
Chadwick boseman's death on August 28
2020 devastated fans around the world
and the cast and crew of Black Panther
and in the wake of his passing his
deathblood to an issue that many fans
had with the sequel specifically Ryan
coogler and Kevin feige's staunch
refusal to recast t'challa in Black
Panther 2. in an interview with Empire
feige acknowledged it just felt like it
was much too soon to recast as
extraordinary and Fantastical as our
characters and stories are there is a
relatable and human element to
everything we do the world is still
processing the loss of Chad Bozeman made
t'challa an icon and a role model to
many with the actor himself just as
entangled with the character as Robert
Downey Jr and Chris Evans have been with
Iron Man and Captain America nonetheless
there are still a lot of fans who are
not just disappointed but outraged by
the idea of a Black Panther movie with
no t'challa even knowing that the role
would have to be recast to make it
happen for instance a Twitter user wrote
we had one black male superhero and
y'all killed him after one movie and as
another user points out it's not like
the MCU hasn't recast before with Don
Cheadle taking over the role of War
Machine from Terence Howard and Harrison
Ford set to replace the late William
Hurt as general Thunderbolt Ross in the
upcoming Thunderbolts
Bozeman's death necessitated a vastly
different approach to the sequel story
especially considering that writer
director Ryan coogler decided not to
recast the hero this meant that a
different character would have to take
the mantle which ended up falling to
t'challa's Super Genius scientist sister
shuri of course for that plot to work
the movie would also have to explain to
chala's absence and since they didn't
have a way to have Chadwick on screen
without a creepy looking deep fake it
meant they instead decided to have the
character of t'challa die off-screen to
be fair there was no real way to do that
in a satisfying way this is especially
true without Bozeman or the willingness
to use a stand-in kukler made the wisest
decision he could by having the death
happen quickly at the beginning of the
film however many fans were
understandably upset by this decision
including one Twitter user who brought
up the fact that wakanda's super science
seems Advanced enough to cure pretty
much any mortal illness after all in the
comics the Black Panther is immune to
disease it's also just very
anticlimactic in general to have your
lead character die off screen however
it's undeniable that there were no great
options for coogler here and they did a
great job with the route they took
one of the highlights of black panther
wakanda forever is the live-action
reveal of the classic Marvel anti-hero
Namor played to Perfection by a Mexican
actor tanoch Huerta who has been
justifiably outspoken about colorism and
discrimination in the entertainment
industry even better the character is
also very comic book accurate in his
appearance down to Neymar's patented
pointy elf ears skimpy green Trunks and
even the goofy Wings on his feet that
let him fly Ryan coogler was able to
make Neymar work as a compelling and
cool character on screen despite all the
ways the character could have gone wrong
Neymar even yells out his comic book
Battle Cry of imperious wrecks during
the climax of the film however one of
the big changes the film makes to
Neymar's backstory is the fact that
instead of being from Atlantis Namor
hails from the Mesoamerican Fallen
Kingdom of talocon loosely based on
Mayan mythology do not call him
they called him
feather serpent Court there were a
variety of reasons for the change from
The Source material including possibly
to avoid comparison to DC's Blockbuster
Aquaman movies starring Jason Momoa also
it's a nice way to add more diversity
and representation to the MCU and the
superhero movie landscape in general
unfortunately While most fans appreciate
the MCU adaptation of Neymar's backstory
some were not so happy about the change
in the Canon there's just no pleasing
some people who've grown attached to
every detail of comic book lore
most fans of black panther wakanda
forever appreciated the change to
Neymar's backstory especially in how it
allowed more indigenous representation
to be included in a blockbuster
superhero film however even some of
those fans who appreciated what feige
and coogler had in mind for the mcu's
version of Namor had other issues with
how the character was portrayed in the
Black Panther sequel for instance in the
original Marvel Comics Neymar is known
for being stubborn strong-willed and a
bit of a lasario while a lot of that is
still intact in the Cinematic version
some vocal fans were disappointed with
how he was so easily defeated in the end
admittedly some of these opinions stem
from sexist ideas believing that shuri
shouldn't have been given the Black
Panther mantle but other fans have made
more cogent points as one Reddit user
wrote If Neymar carried a bottle of
water with him he would be Invincible
also why didn't he go take a sip of
water when shuri was stunned before
starting the fight also while he and
shuri certainly seemed to have some
chemistry as he showed her around
talocon he's not as overtly leery as he
is in the source material of course
that's probably a good thing all thing
things considered
the original 2018 black panther film is
rightfully heralded as not only a great
Marvel movie and an outstanding
superhero film but as simply a good film
in general it can even include a
nomination for best picture at the 2019
Academy Awards among its many accolades
however despite the praise from critics
and fans alike the somewhat janky CGI
was always a big and consistent
complaint about the film and it's not
unfounded either especially during the
final fight between t'challa and Michael
B Jordan's killmonger underneath wakanda
to be fair this issue isn't a problem
with black panther or wakanda forever
specifically as a lot of recent
Blockbusters have been burdened with an
overabundance of shoddy VFX work
nonetheless a lot of the CGI and black
panther wakanda forever feels
undercooked with fans on Tick Tock
comparing Riri Williams overly shiny
Iron Heart armor to a Power Rangers
costume honestly it's a point that's
hard to argue with despite ironheart's
otherwise welcome addition to the cast
one of the chief complaints lobbed at
the Marvel Cinematic Universe especially
since 2012's Avengers is the overly
quippy and self-referential Whedon speak
Batman is playing Galaga
thought we wouldn't notice
but we did worse that kind of patented
overly snarky and irreverent dialogue
that the MCU has traded in for over a
decade has been seeping into other
movies as well becoming the de facto
mode of conversation for way too many
Blockbusters this has led to an
inevitable backlash towards the MCU by
critics and fans alike especially
considering its ubiquity across the
entire entertainment industry fans
eventually started complaining about how
the MCU now had far too many jokes the
stakes started to feel non-existent and
every character had the same quippy
attitude despite their disparate
backgrounds and Origins luckily many
fans were happy to discover that black
panther wakanda forever had a much more
serious tone it makes sense considering
the entire film is grappling with heavy
topics like grief the devastating
effects of imperialism and the death of
its previous star hanging over it
unfortunately some fans didn't
appreciate the change in tone or at the
very least didn't appreciate just how
dark and depressive it got one Twitter
user wrote that the mood was too serious
another Twitter user comedically
showcased the change in tone and
perspective between the two black
panther films by showing two very
different moments in the same James
Corden skit there was probably no way
given the unfortunate behind the scenes
circumstances of the film that wakanda
forever would be as fun as the first
black panther however it also makes
sense that many fans would rather have
come to watch an Escapist fantasy rather
than a sobering meditation on Grief and
loss
another of the small handful of
criticisms faced by the first black
panther film was about the inclusion of
a good guy CIA agent Everett Ross the
concept feels disingenuous as in the
real world the CIA has been at the
Forefront of toppling many
democratically elected governments
around the world this has particularly
affected nations in Africa and Central
and South America cultures that inspired
wakanda and talocon the U.S has played a
part in stripping those nations of their
natural resources which is not too
dissimilar to Western Nations desire to
obtain vibranium in the films even the
Black Panther films in the MCU don't shy
away from the agency's terrible and
imperialist atrocities it's a major plot
point in Black Panther wakanda forever
that the US government operating via
agent Ross's ex-wife CIA director
Valentina Allegra de Fontaine is behind
a plan to steal both wakanda and
talocon's vibranium by any means
necessary a Twitter user stated the
issues with the film's political framing
pretty plainly in an insightful tweet
absolutely hilarious how wakanda forever
seamlessly goes from this dangerous
indigenous extremist wants his land back
that's messed up to anyway let's check
in with our lovable CIA scam this is not
to say that there isn't any Nuance in
coogler and the mcu's depiction of the
CIA but it could still do better in
grappling with the issue
the cast member who stands out most of
all in the Black Panther films is Angela
Bassett who plays t'challa and shuri's
mother the wise and Regal Queen ramonda
in Black Panther wakanda forever
bassett's Queen ramonda has taken over
diplomatic Affairs for wakanda after
t'challa's untimely death she does this
as powerful Western Nations like France
and the United States attempt to
undermine wakanda's sovereignty and gain
access to their vibranium these attempts
lead those governments to the ocean
where they find Neymar's Kingdom of
talocon unbeknownst to the rest of the
world namor's people have their own
reserve of vibranium as well because of
this Neymar attempts to broker a truce
with wakanda which doesn't go well and
eventually Neymar attacks wakanda and
drowns Queen raimonda I need to know
this one was an intentional move by the
filmmakers to make viewers upset the
sadness and Melancholy were the desired
effect Ryan coogler wanted and he
certainly did succeed if social media is
anything to go by just see the reaction
from Twitter users reacting with
statements like Queen Mother get up to
get this out of the way up front when it
comes to portraying shuri's Journey from
grief to her acceptance of the mantle of
black panther Leticia Wright absolutely
kills it in wakanda Forever she more
than steps into the vibranium shoes left
by Chadwick Boseman as she showcases a
wide range of emotions while handling
the action scenes with immense skill not
only is she asked to do more in the
sequel but she Nails every aspect of her
performance outside the movie though
it's been disheartening for many fans to
find out that between Black Panther and
wakanda forever Wright took to spreading
anti-vaxx and bigoted anti-trans
conspiracy theories upon facing backlash
for her comments she only doubled down
rather than apologizing or retracting
them there have also been reports
alleging that she was responsible for a
coveted scare on the wakanda forever set
because of all this some fans
understandably struggled to separate the
actor from her character such as a
Twitter user who wrote It's a shame
Leticia Wright had and seemingly
continues to have that anti-vaxx
controversy considering shuri's Arc In
wakanda Forever is perfect and she gives
an incredible performance that I really
wasn't expecting from her
unlike most films in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe black panther wakanda
forever doesn't have an after credit
sequence in fact it's one of the only
films in the entire MCU to not have one
there is a mid-credit sequence in
wakanda Forever which is a beautiful and
emotional coda in which shuri is then
greeted by Nakia and the son she
secretly had with t'challa he's named
after his father possibly setting him up
to reclaim the Black Panther mantle in
later sequels all of that aside there
was a persistent rumor from legitimate
Outlets like The Hollywood Reporter that
none other than Victor Von Doom was
going to be introduced in an after
credit Stinger at the end of black
panther wakanda forever what is this
Victor Von Doom is on here now this
could have been true at one point but
then changed to let the Black Panther
film end on Hope and renewal or the
rumors were unfounded and he was you
ever intended to appear either way the
iconic Marvel villain does not reveal
himself in Black Panther wakanda forever
that didn't stop certain fans from
getting upset with one Twitter user
posting a meme of someone putting on
clown makeup and crying
[Music]